is gambling legal in
Australia I yes we have casinos so I'm
going to say yes I don't gamble a lot so
yeah like you know you know what I find
about adult film stars they're more
conservative than regular people in
weird way wholesome more wholesome you
guys are really wholesome it's really
all the ones that I know are just good
conservative you know they don't swear a
lot they don't spit on the
sidewalk they don't they they follow the
rules people do that yeah man you know
civilian you know whatever but but um
adult they're just we're very clean very
clean nice people organized also
punctual and also um I'm I'm being real
and also very responsible mm this woman
ran for office I know she did I read it
yeah did you win uh I I got the result
that I wanted I wouldn't have wanted to
win cuz I wouldn't know what to do in
that position
can you explain to the audience what you
ran for yeah yeah um so I was running
against a greens candidate Kathleen
Molson and her platform was about um
shutting down all the brothels in
Melbourne which actually like she
claimed to be a feminist that cared
about the women but any person involved
in the work will tell you that once you
close it down you send it underground
you make it more dangerous so it's
actually worse for the sex workers when
you do something like that so my whole
platform was just to draw attention to
the fact that Kathleen molon was running
on this campaign and she was running for
the greens which is usually very
Progressive usually very like sex
positive sex worker friendly but not in
this case um so I just wanted to draw
votes away from her so she didn't win
cuz she had a strong chance of winning
and she didn't win so aming I achieved
what I wanted to achieve if I had won
that would have
been incredible suppose you would have
won let's suppose you would have won
what would the first thing you would
done been
well um well you have a degree in gender
studies right yeah you know you could
you could figure it out I'd figure it
out sure but like and guess what every
day you'd be
[Laughter]
punctual cly wouldn't have shut down the
brothel um I would have made porn is
kind of like a gray area in the lore in
Australia like it's it's not necessarily
illegal but it's not fully legal so I
would have like looked into that um but
actually listening to the constituents
like all they wanted was for me to
address the traffic on hotle Street like
I have nightmares about the traffic on
hotle Street everyone every town meeting
was what are you going to do about the
traffic on huddle street so I don't know
I would what's going on huddle Street oh
it's busy so much
traffic why I guess cuz there's just no
other route to right
yeah what would you do well nothing's
being done after all these well think
that's British it is I'm sorry I'm just
going to do my own version of what well
the traffic in hotle
Street Hogwarts Legacy five yeah
Harry yo is it now yeah yeah yeah no um
I just could of just do my old regular
accent or no yeah your own excuse me
what's up well can I just say thank you
for voting for me yeah what's up Sir can
we please address I would love to
address anything that you would like the
traffic and what stre I look at the
diagrams okay and I looked at the infr
structure what was that the
infrastructure got it right and I lo
also looked at the piping yep and all
the canals everything that makes up
hudle streight the cement the layout and
I looked at the diagrams and this is
what I found out what we do is we we
build a second Road just above huddle
Street God this guy's a
genius how are we going to Road what H
who will pay thank you who will pay for
this well the the Australian people will
pay my friend oh we don't like that it's
enough tax why we voted for you we're
not you're not going to be taxed more so
where will the money come from I'm going
to tell you right now all right [__]
are you taking our teacher salaries no
we're not taking that for the Skyway no
dude we're getting rid of certain Sports
what yeah riots Australia you're going
to take away sports only two sports what
are our national sports I'll tell you
the two sports I don't like them they're
too violent okay so
rugby that's our thing I don't care and
soccer you're going to be taken out no I
won't because this
road the second Ro who will build the
road me and my [__] Asian friends
what oh oh my whole crew is Asian what
are you talking about they're all
[__] we're all chemists and and [__]
have chemist build road we we're all
chemists and we're all [__] engineers
and we're going to figure it out dude
you can have the best [__] Road in
holl Street you're right and we're just
not going to watch a [__] rugby
anymore got it okay so what do you guys
think
all right what you this guy's my guy I
like it he's my yes man what do you
think it's good
stuff all right yeah how about this we
get rid of
um I know what we do I got it I got it
right here okay because would you work
for my
Administration I'm asking everyone in
this room will you work I just won okay
will you all work for my Administration
absolutely but can we start with the
Australian national anthem first led by
can we start no can we start with this
is